gestern Nachmittag war das Desaster bei
der Fußball-WM in Katar perfekt die
Pleite gegen Japan ein verzagt
agierender DFB gegen die Anmaßungen der
Infantino Truppe die one love-binde am
Arm der Sportministerin anstatt beim
Nationaltorhüter auf Leidenschaft und
Freude am Fußball hofft man da wohl
vergeblich im Abseits die Fußball-WM in
Katar jetzt in der phönix-rund
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio waldemar Hartmann ist bei
uns ehemaliger Sportmoderator der ARD
sie haben einen Großteil der in den
letzten Jahrzehnten stattgefundenen Welt
und Europameisterschaften mitgemacht 11
mal olympische Winter und Sommerspiele
und das ganze Drumherum hautnah
miterlebt über tekal ist bei uns
ehemalige profifußballerin Trainerin und
sozialunternehmerin sie engagieren sich
und Projekt scoring Girls scoring Girls
heißt ein Projekt für geflüchtete junge
Mädchen die sonst keinen Zugang zu Sport
hätten Philipp Köster ist Schäfer
Redakteur des fußballmagazins 11 Freunde
und unter anderem Mitglied der Deutschen
Akademie für Fußballkultur ihrem Jahres
Kettner ist bei uns Unternehmens und
Politikberater und ein Experte in Sachen
katarisch deutsche Beziehungen dazu
haben sie auch promoviert und es geht
vor allem um die Bereiche Wirtschaft
Politik
und Gesellschafter hat man die WM in
Katar die ist nicht die erste Umstände
Großveranstaltung es gab vor vier Jahren
die Weltmeisterschaft in Russland in
diesem Jahr noch die Winterspiele in
China müssen wir uns an solche
umstrittenen vergaben von Sport-Events
gewöhnen ich fürchte ja den in
Deutschland hat schon drei oder vier
Bewerber für Olympische Spiele gegeben
und die sind jeweils nicht zustande
gekommen weil die Bevölkerung sie
abgelehnt hat das war in Leipzig so das
war in Hamburg so das war in Berlin so
das war in München so und dann landen
die irgendwo irgendwann in Auto bei
autokratisch Herrschern und ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie es weitergehen soll also
die Vereinigten Staaten gelten noch als
Weltmeisterschaften
Mexiko zusammen
ich fürchte dass wir uns damit
anfreunden müssen dass diese öfterefall
sein wird Frau total als ehemalige
profifußballerin wissen Sie ja am besten
was in solchen Situationen wie jetzt in
Katar auch in den Spielern vorgeht
einerseits wollen sie auf keinem Auge
blind sein sie wollen sie auch gegen
Ungerechtigkeit Wenden auf der anderen
Seite wollen sie natürlich auch
sportlichen Erfolg haben wie muss man
sich diesen Druck da vorstellen
in erster Linie ist es glaube ich
wichtig zu wissen dass das eine das
andere nicht ausschließt und ich glaube
das ist das ähm was ich in erster Linie
sagen möchte weil klar ich liebe diesen
Sport und ich habe ihn viele Jahre
gespielt und ich weiß auch ungefähr was
in den Spielern vorgeht oder
Spielerinnen die vielleicht ein bisschen
unter Druck gesetzt werden sich zu
äußern aber ich bin felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass eben wir nicht nur
sportliche Vorbilder sind in diesem
Moment sondern eben auch politische
Vorbilder und dass die Zeiten vorbei
sind wo wir schweigen und nicht sagen
und deswegen auch da eine Verantwortung
haben und laut sein müssen jetzt muss
man ja eine Unterscheidung machen
zwischen dem Austragungsort also dem
Emirat Katar und den Veranstalter das
ist ja nicht der Emir sondern dass die
tiefer sind das eigentlich die die
eigentlichen Männer wenn es um die
Fragen geht Vergabe mit korrektiven mit
Korruptionen die Relativierung von
Menschenrechten
von Vielfalt ist müssen wir uns zwar
eher an die FIFA als an Katar halten bei
dieser Weltmeisterschaft na da haben ja
alle ihre Rolle gespielt Katar das
mutmaßlicher diverse Mitglieder des FIFA
exekutiv Communitys geschmiert hat die
FIFA die kein moralisches Geländer hatte
als es darum ging wo vergeben wir
eigentlich dieses Turnier hin überhaupt
diese ganze moralische Verwahrlosung die
wir dort erleben wo man das Gefühl hat
alles was in irgendeiner Weise an sagen
wir mal moralischen
moralischen Anforderungen da ist wird so
sehr gedehnt und immer wieder in
perverse Zusammenhänge gestellt dass am
Ende nichts mehr eine Bedeutung hatte
also man konnte ja als man
beispielsweise Jenny Infantino den FIFA
Präsidenten in seiner Pressekonferenz
gehört hat konnte man ja denken so ein
Menschenrechtler vor dem Herrn also wenn
man nicht wüsste dass alles was er sagt
genau das Gegenteil ist von dem was er
macht er Kinder eine
Fußballweltmeisterschaft soll ja nicht
nur Brücken bauen zwischen den
teilnehmenden Ländern soll ja auch ist
ja auch das gute Recht ist
austragungslandes dessen Image
aufpolieren haben sich die Master
kalkuliert was das Image angeht
eine sehr gute Frage und das werden wir
noch sehen ob es eine miskalkulation war
aber sie haben das angesprochen
Katar was wollte Katar damit es wollte
auf die Landkarte es wollte bekannt
werden das nennt man in der
Politikwissenschaft softpower das heißt
man möchte über solche sportmedia Events
oder eben auch über Kultur und Bildung
über sich reden machen nicht es gibt in
der zwei Kollegen von mir haben das
beschrieben ein ein softpower des
Empowerment Nexus das heißt natürlich es
kann sein wenn du so im Line Leid stehst
und eben dann auch die sehr viel
negativen Sachen mit hochgeschwemmt
werden dass das zum Teil auch nach
hinten losgehen kann aber das Ziel von
Katar wurde erstmal erreicht jetzt kennt
man Katar und man weiß es ist ein
ernstzunehmender Akteur ich rede gar
nicht mehr so sehr um den Sport es geht
ja um Gas es geht um Investitionen es
geht um wirtschaftliche Beziehung und es
geht auch zunehmend um Katar als
Mediator in internationalen Konflikt
würden Sie denn als jemand der gut
Präsident und auch für die die
Beziehungen dorthin pflegt sie sind ja
eben auch Berater in diesen Bereichen
würden Sie sagen es war die Vergabe an
katawand Fehler aus welcher Sicht fragen
Sie das also jetzt natürlich aus der die
diskutieren weniger der sportlichen da
könnte man ja auch drüber reden ob
tiefgekühlte Stadien mit in der Wüste so
gut sind aber auch jetzt aus der
politischen aus der sportpolitischen
Sicht also ich fand was Herr Hartmann
hier eingangs gesagt hatte eine relativ
gute Analyse und auch eine sehr
realistische Einschätzung denn man muss
sich ja immer überlegen wer macht es
denn eigentlich sonst noch und wenn sich
dann Katar bewirbt also alles was zu
kritisieren ist und was da im Raum steht
das soll auch kritisiert werden nur am
Ende des Tages ist es ja von meines
Erachtens auch okay wenn eine WM in die
arabische Welt mal geht und wo soll die
sonst hingehen es gibt 22 arabische
Staaten aber nur die arabischen
Golfstaaten die im cheesy Sie
zusammengefasst sind haben ja auch die
finanziellen Mittel sowas wirklich
auszutragen
auf ich glaube 2010 war die Entscheidung
der FIFA die WM nach Katar zu geben das
sind 12 einhalb Jahre
es gab immer wieder Kritik auch daran
also an den
Umweltfragen Stichwort dass man
klimatisierte Stadien damit in die Wüste
stellt die miese Behandlung der
Gastarbeiterinnen und Gastarbeiter dort
aber das ist jetzt so zehn zwölf Tage
vor der WM plötzlich hochkommen und alle
Welt darüber diskutiert was man 12 Jahre
vorher schon hätte machen können
wir dann nur Reflexen oder ist das eine
Nachlässigkeit auch der
Weltöffentlichkeit viel zu spät dieses
Thema entdeckt zu haben also definitiv
sind wir viel zu spät dran darüber zu
berichten und dennoch sage ich dass es
gut ist das gerade die ganze
Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt ist viele
NGOs und viele ähm
jungen white Swatch the international
wie sie alle heißen die haben schon sehr
viele Jahre darauf aufmerksam gemacht
was da eigentlich passiert es hat nur
niemand hingehört und es hat niemand
hingeguckt und ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig ich das in diesem Fall also die
Frage die sie vielleicht gerade an ihnen
gestellt haben ich finde es war ein
Riesenfehler diese Weltmeisterschaft
nach Katar zu geben ich sage aber nicht
dass wir nicht
eine Weltmeisterschaft der Länder geben
können die keine fußball-tradition haben
aber es ist wichtig dass wir das an
bestimmte Bedingungen verknüpfen und wir
haben dieses Land was Menschenrechte
verletzt auch noch mit dieser
Weltmeisterschaft so sehe ich das
belohnt weil wir auch noch diese
Weltmeisterschaft dahin gegeben haben
wissentlich dass all das wofür
eigentlich was gebraucht wird für diese
Weltmeisterschaft gar nicht zur
Verfügung steht sei es die Infrastruktur
die heißt die Spanien man wusste man
geht ein Risiko ein und man ist dieses
Risiko ganz bewusst eingegangen und da
muss ich sagen da ist man Menschenrechts
Herz einfach ein bisschen höher und das
verstehe ich dann wiederum nicht
findet sich da die FIFA vielleicht sogar
als Entwicklungshilfe denn die hat ja in
ihren Statuten stehen dass sie für
Menschenrechte und die Diversität
Eintritt das was man hier jetzt gar
nicht mehr abnimmt wie ist diese Rolle
dazu versteht verstößt sich ständig
durch gegen ihre eigenen Statuten naja
diese Entwicklungshilfe war für die
eigenen Kassen von fünf oder sechs
Mitgliedern des Exekutivkomitees niedern
fünf Jahre später nach der Vergabe
morgens um halb sechs im Hotel borlak in
Zürich vom FBI mit Hilfe der
Kantonspolizei Zürich abgeholt worden
sind und angeklagt worden sind von der
amerikanischen Justizministerin die
Retter wünscht das ist die eine Sache
sie haben gesagt wir vergeben wir
vergeben keine WM die FIFA vergibt diese
WM das ist das Problem an der ganzen
Geschichte ich will es ausführlich an
ich will nur feststellen dass die
Mehrheit die Mehrheit dieser 22
damals diese WM vergeben hat
Sepp Platte der heute so tut und
kokettierend durch die Schweiz zieht und
infantilo seine Landsmann angreift der
zehn Kilometer von ihm weg im Wallis auf
die Welt gekommen ist war damals der
Präsident und er tut so und Tat damals
so als ob er damit nichts zu tun hätte
mit der Begründung er hätte für die USA
gestimmt also der große der große Knall
der der Urknall war dass nach Katar zu
geben in ein Land ich bin bei ihnen darf
man muss nicht unbedingt Fußball aber da
war nicht sie werden das bestätigen es
gab kein Fußballstadion es wurde Fußball
vor 50 zuschauen und die sind meistens
erst zu Halbzeit gekommen
es war nichts da und man hat es dort
hingegeben dann hätte man sie haben es
angesprochen zwölf Jahre Zeit gehabt
dann hat man erst mal festgestellt umso
ist es heiß da hat man bis 2015
gebraucht um diese WM dann in den Winter
zu verlegen das wäre der Tag gewesen wo
wir gesagt hat müssen wir die wirklich
dahin geben dann hat 2015 eine Handball
Weltmeisterschaft übrigens nicht die
einzige WM die dort stattgefunden hat
Tischtennis gleichzeitig haben sie alle
gekauft um den Plan von ihnen wir müssen
auf der Landkarte erscheinen zu erfüllen
bei der Handball WM und jetzt kommt mein
Vorwurf habe ich keinen Bogen Trikot
gesehen ich habe nichts gesehen es gab
keinen keine Demonstration es gab
öffentlich keinen Widerspruch obwohl die
die damals Handball gespielt haben
wirklich eingekauft worden sind und
werden katarischen Schäferhund hattest
der alte Spruch vom Eishockey der wurde
dann Katara und konnte das Spiel die
Fehler wurden vor 12 Jahren gemacht noch
mal vor 6 Jahren was jetzt stattfindet
ist zum Selbstzweck eine bekenntnisvolle
die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann weil
ich will eine Fußballweltmeisterschaft
sehen das heißt also der Fußball also
wenn man sagt es waren schon andere
Sportarten dort in Katar vor Ort gewesen
aber Fußball ist noch eine andere
Dimension die das dann sozusagen
richtig öffentlich macht naja also ich
finde es nicht verwunderlich dass du vor
einer Weltmeisterschaft im Fußball eine
der größten Sportarten der Welt ist eine
besondere Resonanz gibt und die Handball
Weltmeisterschaft ist auch nicht völlig
kritiklos von Stadt gegangen also schon
damals gab es sehr viel negative Presse
über die sie zusammengekaufte
Mannschaften genau aber nicht über die
Zustände nicht über die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen nicht über
schwulen die keine Rechte haben alle die
gesellschaftlichen Themen viele waren
kein ja aber der fehlende Protest von
damals nicht den Protest von heute also
ich finde man kann schon sagen das hat
nach wie vor die Berechtigung jetzt
Öffentlichkeit herzustellen und man muss
eben auch sagen all die Leute die
darüber gemeckert haben die gesagt haben
das geht so nicht haben damals in der
Öffentlichkeit keine Resonanz gefunden
also jetzt hat man offenbar eine
Projektionsfläche auf der das global
wahrgenommen wird damals werden
beispielsweise bei 11 Freunde sicherlich
sehr sehr viele Artikel 5678 große
Meinungsartikel über diese Vergabe
geschrieben haben es kritisiert am Ende
haben die Leute gesagt es ist noch zu
weit weg wir blicken nicht 2017 oder
2015 auf 2022 ich glaube nur dieser Satz
ich will eine Fußball-WM sehen die
funktioniert nicht wenn einem an
Fußballkultur gelegen ist also für mich
ist ganz entscheidend zu schauen in
welchem Umfeld findet Fußball den statt
also ich kann das nicht so sehr
ausblenden zu sagen ach ich gucke es
einfach nur auf den grünen Rasen und die
schauen nicht ob da Leute die innere
Regenbogen T-Shirt anhaben nicht in
Stadion kommen und ich glaube nicht
absprechen dass ich Fußballkultur habe
ich habe aber ich wünsche euch Kultur
Betrieben ja ich würde dir wünschen wenn
du tatsächlich so verbunden bist mit der
Fußballkultur das eben nicht
auszublenden sondern zu sagen mir ist es
wichtig in welchem Stadion in welchem
Land in unter Umständen der stattfindet
also gerade als Verfechter der
Fußballkultur sollte man das tun ich
glaube auch dass es eben genau darum
geht nicht irgendwie blind auch zu sagen
ich boykottiere diese Weltmeisterschaft
sondern
wie bei Gott die ich diese
Weltmeisterschaft und mein Empfinden ist
einfach dass es mittlerweile ganz
konstruktiven bei Gott gibt nämlich eine
ganz kritische Auseinandersetzung mit
dieser Weltmeisterschaft die sind
natürlich sehr sehr viel mit sich zieht
aber ich finde es auch sehr wichtig ich
trainiere junge geflüchtete Mädchen die
aus Unrechtsregime geflohen sind die
kommen hier in dieses Land und fragen
mich wie kann es sein dass für eine
Weltmeisterschaft Menschen sterben das
für Fußball den wir so lieben und der
uns so viel gibt Menschen sterben so und
jetzt beantworten sie mal 12 13
14-jährigen Mädchen diese Frage
machen sie das mal versuchen Sie das mal
in Worte zu fassen was das eigentlich
konkret bedeutet und ich glaube was ich
auch sehr sehr wichtig finde ich bin ja
ich habe ja auch eine
Menschenrechtsorganisation gegründet als
Minderheit in der Minderheit und ich
weiß wie es ist wenn eben nicht
hingeguckt wird wenn nicht laut wenn
wenn man nicht laut ist wenn die
Menschen die eine Stimme haben sie nicht
nutzen für eben Minderheiten ich weiß
wie sich das anfühlt ich weiß genau was
das bedeutet
und deswegen ist es mir wichtig in
diesem Fall tatsächlich die Stimme zu
sein und ich ich liebe das dass das
gerade hier durch dieses Land auch geht
die Stimme zu sein für diejenigen die
eben nicht laut sein können und wir
können uns dieser Verantwortung nicht
entziehen und das meine ich auch mit wir
wenn ich sage wir mit wir meine ich auch
unseren nationalen Verband der natürlich
auch Druck ausüben kann wie er als
Zivilbevölkerung können Druck ausüben
auf die FIFA das das geht da gebe ich
Ihnen Recht dass die FIFA dann natürlich
ganz viele Mist gebaut hat das wissen
wir alles in der Vergabe und allem was
da passiert ist aber es ist auch muss
doch unser aller Anspruch sein dass wir
es schaffen da so einen Druck auszuüben
dass das eben nicht noch mal passiert
wir können ja nicht sagen
oder der ist Mitglied dieser FIFA und
den ersten Zugriff Druck auszuüben hätte
der
dfbälle vielleicht in ergänzen
die Katara diese Kritik auf die bekommen
sie ja irgendwie auch ja bevor ich auch
eigentlich noch ganz kurz zum
vorhergesagten was vorteca zum Beispiel
sagte finde ich spannend weil eigentlich
heißt es ja ein Rückschluss dass es für
dich jetzt auch gut ist dass so eine
Aufmerksamkeit auf diese Themen kommen
weil ich kann mich gut erinnern an ein
Zitat ich habe 120 Interviews für meine
Doktorarbeit geführt mit allen
Entscheidungsträgern von 99 bis 2013 in
Katha und Deutschland Politik Wirtschaft
Gesellschaft und ein deutscher
Spitzenmanager sagte damals zu mir
meinst du ernsthaft dass ich jemand
interessiert wie die Arbeitsbedingungen
auf den Baustellen sind der der Boom
setzt ja schon Anfang der 2000er Jahre
ein wenn jetzt jemand das kritisiert zu
Recht kritisiert finde ich das auch
glaubhaft wenn man selber so brennt für
das Thema Menschenrechtsorganisation hat
jeder kann das für sich selber einordnen
das ist gut so ich sage auch es gibt
viele Sachen zu kritisieren und jetzt
komme ich zu Ihrer Frage
es ist die Frage wie man das macht und
in den internationalen Beziehungen in
der Diplomatie das medienmechanismen
funktionieren anders als Diplomatie aber
ich würde das empfehlen etwas leiser zu
machen weil der Westen als Gesam Gottes
macht sich sonst auch zu leicht den
Vorwurf der Doppelmoral im aussätzlich
und und muss es sich zum Teil auch
berechtigterweise sogar schon anhören
und natürlich wird das in Katar
beobachtet und zwar nicht nur in Katar
sondern da wird dann im arabischen Raum
auch zusammengestanden und ich habe das
Eröffnungsspiel zusammen mit arabischen
Diplomaten hier sehen können in Berlin
und das war nicht der katarische
Botschafter aber ein anderer den ich
jetzt nicht nennen möchte der ganz klar
der der nicht nur verärgert war sondern
der regelrecht wie soll ich sagen also
der das war sehr emotional und er meinte
er meinte und das noch abschließend
sie sollen mal abwarten uns nicht zu
weit treiben weil wir haben sonst dann
auch noch Möglichkeiten Firmen
auszuschließen von Aufträgen etc und
darum geht es am Ende
das Problem dass wir uns überhaupt
erpressbar machen erpressbar in welchem
Sinne
von Deutschland also sagt klar
politischen Entscheidung von politischen
Entscheidungsträgern von Leuten aus dem
Wirtschaftsbereich das ist ja genau das
was ich meine ich glaube dass wir uns
nicht gut tun daran und jedes Mal
erpressbar zu machen in irgendeine
Meinung von Herrn Hartmann interessieren
können das Beantworten also
unsere Bundeswirtschaftsminister war ja
im März dort umflüssigkeit rein zu
kaufen also die sind natürlich in der
Tat auch wirtschaftlich von diesem
gerade von von Katar aber nichts
geworden ist und es wird ähm weil
Deutschland die Vertragslaufzeit nur 20
Jahren haben möchte noch eine Frage wenn
wir aber man kann doch feststellen dass
inzwischen in der Welt hat es gerade in
der Welt des Fußballs auch doch sehr
viel mehr Sensibilität da ist ich
erinnere mich an die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
1978 da waren sie noch gar nicht auf der
Welt in Argentinien in einem Land das
von einem mörderischen militärischen
damals beherrscht worden ist der
DFB-Präsident damals Hermann Neuberger
hat das alles gesund geredet weil alles
halb so schlimm die FIFA hat kein Wort
gesagt das haben Fußballspiele
stattgefunden und leben dran wurden
Menschen zu Tode gefoltert im Gefangenen
Lagern also wenn man diese Zeit 78 bis
heute sieht dann hat sich doch vieles
auch wird auch vieles angesprochen und
diskutiert also es ist eine gewisse
Sensibilität da das hat natürlich auch
was damit zu tun dass Fußball eine
völlig andere Bedeutung in der
Gesellschaft hat also wir haben ja ganz
viele soziale Milieus die sich aufgelöst
haben katholische Milieu Parteien Milieu
und der Fußball ist die letzte große
gesellschaftsrillionen die quasi alle
irgendwas zu sagen können es ist
Gesprächsthema und natürlich ist es eine
ganz andere Projektionsfläche geworden
und wird natürlich auch komplett anders
in so einem gesellschaftlichen
verantwortungskontext gestellt der Punkt
ist nur wenn es folgenlos bleibt ist es
völlig egal wie gesellschaftlich
bedeutend das ist also wenn es nach wie
vor möglich ist dass wir ohne
moralisches Geländer ohne ethische
Kriterien so eine WM nach Katar vergeben
können dann ist natürlich ein großes
Problem da und ich warne auch so ein
bisschen davor dass man jetzt sagt was
geschieht da alles an Unrecht also man
muss tatsächlich sagen seit 2010 seitdem
diese WM dorthin vergeben worden ist
sind die Einwohner von Katar der Stadt
Katar sehr sehr pfleglich behandelt
worden von extrem vielen staatlichen
Stellen von den Medien ich habe bis 2021
sehr sehr wenig darüber gelesen was da
eigentlich alles passiert es gab ein
paar Berichte vom Guardian von MSC
international von human right Sports
aber insgesamt gab es sehr sehr viel
Applaus sehr sehr viel gut will sehr
sehr viel Bereitschaft mal zu gucken was
ich in dem Land so tut insofern kann ich
die Verärgerung dass man kurz vor dem
Turnier das dort noch mal alles
aufploppt das ist sehr sehr viele
Berichte gibt sehr sehr viele Proteste
nicht so richtig verstehen weil klar man
kann ein bisschen beleidigt sein dass es
nicht alle mitfeiern wollen bei dieser
großen Inszenierung aber gleichzeitig
ist eben auch so Katar kann sich
eigentlich über mangelnde Unterstützung
gerade aus der Politik und aus der
Wirtschaft nicht beklagen nein das da
würde ich auch recht geben aber ich
glaube man unterschätzt oftmals
vielleicht auch die Emotionen und es ist
schon sehr emotionales Thema nicht ich
meine klar ist die Fußballkultur anders
dort aber Kater hat in den Fußball-Liga
in dem Jahr gegründet indem sie hier in
Deutschland gegründet wurde
fan-tour ist anders aber ich glaube wir
müssen uns das für gegenwärtigen und ich
habe viel mit Freundinnen und Freunden
dort vor Ort zu tun das ist eine riesen
Sache das ist erste Mal eine WM in einem
arabischen Land und Katar die ja viele
andere Sachen auch als Plattform machen
möchten diese WM natürlich für ihre
ganze arabischen Freunde zu einem Erfolg
machen ja es geht natürlich um die
eigene Sichtbarkeit in der Welt aber es
geht auch um die Sichtbarkeit nach innen
in die arabische Welt aber können sie
uns vielleicht mal erklären das finde
ich ja schon mal interessant
warum setzt zum Beispiel
Qatar dann in der Behandlung von
Reportern in der Behandlung von
Anhängern so auf einen rigidenkurs gibt
es da so wenig PR-Berater büchsenspanner
die ihnen mal sagen liebe Freunde das
sorgt nicht für eine gute Presse im
Westen im globalen Norden wo auch immer
ja ist ein guter Punkt denn die Frage
ist das mache ich zum Teil auch in
meiner Arbeit ich bin kein PR-Berater
aber die Frage ist ja
wer berät sie und wie sind sie
beratungsresistent oder nehmen sie auf
ich würde sagen wie ich das erfahren
habe hören sie zu und sind auch
lernfähig am an am Ende des Tages werden
aber auch Entscheidungen zum Teil
getroffen die für uns schwer
nachvollziehbar sind die aber kulturell
anders ablaufen es ist ein sehr
hierarchisches System dort es ist der
E-Mail an der Spitze es ist im Endeffekt
entfamily Business ich nenne es oft
kataink es ist die Königsfamilie altani
dann gibt es und das ist eine große
Familie mit schätzungsweise 7000
Mitgliedern und dann gibt es drumherum
andere große Familien und das sind
tribale Stammeskulturen da wird in einer
matschis das ist die Institution wo
alles besprochen wird untereinander sich
unterhalten wir im Westen glaube ich das
ist schwer nachzuvollziehen für uns das
ist für mich manchmal auch noch schwer
nachzuvollziehen obwohl ich seit 10
Jahren in Kontakt bin immer mit dem
Interesse ist besser zu verstehen
noch eine Frage vertikal ähm
bringen wir der Kultur solche Länder
doch zu wenig Respekt entgegen also die
Frage ist jetzt sie haben glaube ich
selbst geschrieben
es wird gefährlich wenn sich ein queres
paar in Parteien aller Öffentlichkeit
küsst also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
muslimischen Ländern die beliebte
Touristen und attraktive Touristenziele
sind die vereinigten arabischen
emiratete Oman Indonesien Ägypten
Tunesien Marokko oder sind alles
muslimische Länder und in den
Reiseführern steht immer dass man
Rücksicht auf die Gefühle der
einheimischen Bevölkerung nehmen soll
also nicht im nackten Oberkörper in den
Basar gehen und Frauen nicht mit dem
Bikini Höschen in der Stadt bummeln ist
das ähm müssen wir da nicht vielleicht
auch noch mal überlegen wie diese
Menschen dort und zwar nicht nur der
Emir und nicht nur das macht Gefüge dort
reagiert ich sage ja nicht dass wir
jetzt unsere deutsche Schablone auf
dieses Land legen sollen gut und ich
sage kultursensibilität
ja aber ich sage auch
Menschenrechtsverletzungen nein und ich
sage ganz klar in diesem Moment wo
unsere Innenministerin mit einem
Sicherheitsversprechen zurückkommt und
ganz klar äußert die queere Community
kann jetzt dahin reisen bedenkenlos
alles ist in Ordnung und wir hören aber
paar Tage später von einem sogenannten
wm-botschafter eben genau die Aussage
dass
Homosexuelle irgendwie ein geistigen
Schaden hätten da stelle ich mir die
Frage was ist was ist jetzt eigentlich
also gilt das Sicherheitsversprechen
noch gilt es nicht und deswegen sage ich
ja in diesem Moment aber in diesem
umgeben sagt sie sagt ja ich schenke ihr
glauben
ich habe sie gefragt und sie hat ja
gesagt mehr kann ich nicht glauben
Politikerin und am Ende des Tages ist es
doch auch so dass wir natürlich gewisse
Kulturen also ich komme aus einer Kultur
wo ich also darüber brauchen wir nicht
reden kultursensibilität auf jeden Fall
das auf jeden Fall aber wir reden hier
davon dass wir wie gesagt eine eine
Weltmeisterschaft in ein Land gegeben
haben was eben Menschenrechte massiv
verletzt und das war doch der Fehler da
fängt es doch an und wenn wir von der
Aufmerksamkeit sprechen von dem wir eben
gesprochen haben oder wie wichtig die
ist dass es die jetzt gibt wir sehen es
doch gegenwärtig im Iran was da passiert
und ohne diese Aufmerksamkeit wenn wir
die unsere wenn wir nicht das Sprachrohr
wären für diese Menschen vor Ort die
gegen dieses Unrechtsregime auf die
Straßen gehen wenn wir nicht darauf
aufmerksam machen würden dann würde
niemand davon wissen oder erfahren was
da eben gerade passiert und deswegen
noch einmal wie wichtig es ist auch laut
zu sein und Stellung zu beziehen und die
Zeiten wo wir ruhig sind und leise sind
und schweigen die sind vorbei Punkt also
es geht relativ laut zu es gibt auch
eine ganze Reihe von optischen
Demonstrationen finde ist eine dieser
Demonstration die denen haben auf ihre
wollten auf ihre trainingshemden die
dänischen Nationalmannschaft schreiben
Menschenrecht für alle
das ist von der FIFA untersagt worden
mit dem Argument dass er eine politische
Botschaft und das sei nicht erlaubt bei
Weltmeisterschaften
ich habe mich gefragt wieso das eine
politische Botschaft ist die
Menschenrechte sind universell sie sind
unveräußerlich so steht das in der
Deklaration der Menschenrechte wie kann
die FIFA einen solchen eine solche
absurde Begründung geben um das zu
untersagen die FIFA hat ja die absolute
Ideen die Tat umgesetzt die wir in der
Katar zu geben also was sie fühlt was
die FIFA nicht da aber da bestimmt die
FIFA ganz offensichtlich da das ist der
Ansatz der verstehen sie mich nicht
Katar der Ansatz ist die FIFA dann
machen die so weiter die FIFA hat 233
Verbände mehr als die UNO die hat 195 in
die UEFA hat in Europa 55 Verbände und
sieben davon man muss das schon mal auch
in die Relation setzen sieben davon
haben sich entschieden diese One Love
findet zu tragen sieben nicht mal andere
Europäer waren dabei 13 nehmen nämlich
Teil an dieser WM die Spanier war nicht
dabei hygolorist der Kapitän der
französischen Nationalmannschaft hat zum
Beispiel gesagt nein ich trage sie nicht
weil wir erwarten in Frankreich das
Gäste zu die zu uns kommen sich nach
unseren Regeln und nach unseren Gesetzen
halten also mache ich das auch dort wir
dürfen nicht immer so dieses pauschale
wie er es sind nicht alle es sind sieben
die jetzt dabei waren und ich will das
einfach zitieren da steht den Artikel
13.8.1 bei Fifa finalwettbewerben muss
der Kapitän muss der Kapitän eine jeden
Mannschaft eine von der FIFA
bereitgestellte Binde tragen das wusste
der DFB und dann sind sie so halbweich
da hin und dann sind sie eingeknickt der
DFB muss richtig antreten gegen die FIFA
und muss Verbündete finden sonst reden
wir in fünf Jahren noch in solchen
runden darüber aber ich glaube auch eine
dieser binden die steht ja
notdiskrimination also keine
Diskriminierung dann frage ich mich
natürlich worüber diskutiert wir
eigentlich mit der FIFA also
ich würde ohnehin sogar mal davon raten
dass nicht auf so vermeintlich schwache
Symbole wie diese Binde auch zu
reduzieren also wir sind ohnehin gerade
dabei uns an Symbolen festzuhalten ob es
jetzt nur diese Binde ist ob es eine
Inschrift im Trikot ist oder ob es
dieses Etwas naja rätselhafte Mund zu
halten ist was die deutsche Mann der
Weltbild ja nicht übertragen hat also
als Fernsehbild ja was ohnehin schon mal
klar war dass das sicherlich auch nicht
zu sehen sein wird weil anders als
beispielsweise beim Abfahren der
Nationalhymne ist das eben ein Bild dass
die viel oder auch rausschneiden kann
ich glaube nur es ist eine
Ersatzhandlung auch die deutsche
Mannschaft hat sich ja gefragt was kann
ich eigentlich machen und man ist auf so
naja so ein etwas infantiles und auch
ein sehr halbherziges Symbol gekommen es
wäre an sie Flick unbenommen gewesen den
Spielern unbenommen gewesen politische
Botschaften ein plädoy für
Menschenrechte für Gleichberechtigung
gegen Diskriminierung auch ohne Probleme
in der Pressekonferenz zu sagen es hätte
vielfältige Möglichkeiten gegeben auch
der deutschen Mannschaft Stellung zu
gestalten das hat doch Kimmich gemacht
zwei Tage vor der also ganz ehrlich alle
Äußerungen auf Thomas Müller war Leon
Goretzka würde ich da mal rausnehmen
weil von dem noch das reflektierteste
kam was käme ich gemacht hat was Nico
Schlotter weggemacht hat man merkt
natürlich und das ist auch völlig okay
so das sind Sportler und das sind keine
professionellen Menschenrechtler das
sind Menschen die vor allen Dingen im
Turnier spielen wollen und ich finde das
auch völlig okay und ich finde es auch
gar nicht so dass man sagen würde dass
das ist ihnen abzusprechen aber klar ist
eben auch es ist eigentlich die Aufgabe
des Verbandes es ist die Aufgabe der
Funktionäre des Trainers auch des
Sportdirektors auch von jemandem wie
Oliver Bierhoff da eine klare Position
zu haben nicht rumzueier nicht zu sagen
wir wollen das Thema irgendwie weg haben
und da rechts sich eben dass der DFB das
über elf Jahre weggedrückt hat und jetzt
plötzlich unter Druck versuchen muss
irgendeine Art von moralischen Geländer
zu präsent dass man vielleicht gar nicht
in der Form hat gefehlt woran sich die
Spieler eben auch einfach orientieren
können
während dieser WM Ademi ist 20 mussialer
ist 19 du kannst sie doch nicht mit
politischen Botschaften Aufladen der ist
dort hingefahren zum Fußballspiel das
kann ich doch gar nicht verlangen dafür
sind die auch nicht da das müssen das
müssen das müssen der Präsident machen
wie du du hast ja aufgezählt die müssen
das machen aber das ist die Frage ob ähm
jetzt aus Sicht einer ehemaligen
profi-fußballerin sollten sich
Prominente Profi Sportler auch
gesellschaftspolitisch engagieren sie
sind prominent gelten für viele als
Vorbilder an denen sich viel produziert
an diesen Vorbildern sollten Sie das
machen oder sagt man okay das muss jeder
selbst wissen da eine lebt nur für den
Sport oder die eine und die anderen
machen auch den Mund auf in politischen
Fragen wie also ich finde schon dass man
definitiv zumindest Haltung zeigen kann
und das dann in dem Fall wie man wie ein
Leon Goretzka das beispielsweise gemacht
hat er das ja auch kritisiert hat der
gesagt hat dass stimmt nicht überein mit
meinem Wertekonsens beispielsweise denn
solche Äußerungen trifft und trotzdem
diese Weltmeisterschaft spielt und ich
glaube schon dass das eben geht und dass
das eine das andere nicht ausschließt
ich würde jetzt niemanden vor die Kamera
zerren und zwingen irgendeine Aussage zu
treffen und da sage ich auch da hätte
der Verband auch der DFB natürlich einen
Rahmen schaffen können vor allem ich
weiß dass sie intern viel gemacht haben
in diversen Workshops aber sie hätten
nach außen ihres Statements ganz offen
auch positionieren können damit die
Spieler sich daran orientieren können
und zumindest wissen wie sie dann
vielleicht auch Fragen reagieren und das
ist nicht passiert und dennoch sage ich
dass kein ähm also wir müssen uns von
dem Gedanken verabschieden dass ein
Fußballer oder ein Sportler oder ein
Sportlerin die so viel
Aufmerksamkeit bekommt sich nicht äußern
kannst du politischen Themen das das ist
das ist ganz ehrlich das ist ein etwas
was sich ganz andere gar nicht leisten
können das ist etwas was die in diesem
Fall dann eben auch nutzen können und
wenn man es wirklich vergleichen ich
ziehe diesen Vergleich gerne noch mal
mit den iranischen Sportlern mit denen
die diese Nationalhymne verweigern ja
die in dem Moment nicht nur ihre
sportliche Karriere auf Spiel setzen
sondern eben dass ihre Familien und dass
ihr ihr eigenes Leben auf Spiel setzen
dann kann ich zumindest von einem
Spieler erwarten dass er Position
bezieht ich sage ja nicht dass er sagen
soll alles ist scheiße Entschuldigung
alles ist verkehrt hier ja okay noch mal
zu den Kataris zurückkehren sie haben
gesagt die Wochen auf ihre kulturelle
auf ihre kulturellen Autonomie oder auf
ihre kulturelle Autonomie kann es sein
dass trotzdem etwas von dieser
Diskussion abfärbt etwas hängen bleibt
in dieser Gesellschaft sie ist ja wie
viele arabische Gesellschaften sehr jung
sie ist sehr gut informiert ist viel
besser digitalisiert als Deutschland
zwar keine große Kunst aber
dass da was hängen bleibt ich meine
zunächst noch mal zu der PR-Firma zurück
weil ich habe gerade im Moment drüber
nachgedacht die Frage haben die
richtigen PR Firmen ist eine Frage der
Erwartungshaltung selbst wenn Sie die
richtigen hätten welches narrativ wollen
sie erzählen und jetzt kommen wir zurück
zu der Frage das ist ein Land was ja
innerhalb von den letzten 50 Jahren eine
mega Entwicklung in einer Zeit
durchgemacht hat wo sie 200 für
gebraucht haben also von dem diesen
traditionellen Stammes Gesellschaft wie
sie auch heute noch ticken in 50 Jahren
in die super moderne und wie wenn man
sich das mal auf psychologisch vorstellt
über zwei Generationen drei Generationen
hinweg so eine Entwicklung man hat
dieses Spagat zwischen super Moderne und
Tradition das möchte man auch bewahren
dann muss man schon auch sehen was
wollen die denn dort vor Ort und wo
wollen die hin und ich glaube man sollte
das auch fragen und dann wird man
vielleicht auch eine Antwort bekommen
dass sie eben nicht unbedingt immer das
wollen was wir wollen was wir für gut
heißen und das ich bin auch jemand der
natürlich sehr universelle
Menschenrechte überhaupt nicht
diskutierbar jetzt wenn ich mit
Freunden dort vor Ort auch spreche oder
auch Geschäftskontakten ich hoffe und
denke auch das was abfärben wird weil
sie haben das richtig gesagt diesen
extrem junges Land die kennen uns sehr
viel besser als wir sie weil die in der
Regel auf Ivy League universitys in der
ganzen Welt ausgebildet sind
zurückkommen unsere Ideen und Werte ja
auch mit aufgesogen haben dass dann
vergleichen aber ich glaube trotzdem
innerlich die DNA kulturell ist ist eine
andere und da muss man auch noch sehen
Katar ist auch ein sehr konservatives
Land und die Führung die ist der
westwärts gewandt und progressiv aber so
das groß und wir reden hier also Katar
hat 3 Millionen Einwohner davon sind 10
% nämlich 300 000 € 300.000 € sage ich
das war der deutsche Versprecher 300000
ja also von daher ich würde sagen ja und
ich hoffe dass also ich meine jetzt
schon dass die WM ein Katalysator war
für Entwicklung und für Reformen ich
hoffe eben dass die Aufmerksamkeit dann
nicht abfällt glaube ich aber auch nicht
weil die haben Sport-Events auch in der
ganzen Region und du hast es ja auch
gerade schon noch mal gesagt dass gerade
auch aus Sicht einer
Menschenrechtsorganisation so eine
Aufmerksamkeit ja gut ist weil dann wird
hingeschaut was davor nicht der Fall war
ja und ich möchte trotzdem noch was
sagen es ist wichtig genau das
hingeschaut wird und dennoch möchte ich
sagen ja es hat auch bei uns sehr lange
gedauert bis wir dann eine Demokratie
gelebt haben das stimmt aber wir können
nicht
so viel Zeit wieder verstreichen lassen
weil unser Anspruch muss wirklich sein
dass das wirklich in jedem Land in jedem
Land demokratische Werte gelten und das
zumindest jeder so frei leben kann und
lieben kann wie er möchte oder sie
möchte und jetzt kommt denn ein sage ich
diese Zeit die da verstreichen oder die
dafür streicht die läuft immer auf dem
Rücken von Minderheiten und ich spreche
hier heute für die Minderheit und das
ist mir ganz wichtig und das finde ich
auch ein guter Punkt wenn man sich immer
bei Global anschaut ist ja leider leider
Gottes sind ja Autokratien in der ganzen
Welt auf dem Vormarsch das ist eine
Katastrophe weil es ist nun mal so und
ich glaube wir stehen längst in einem
Wettbewerb des Systeme und wer dieses
diesen Kampf am Ende gewinnt
wird sich nicht an PR-Strategien
entscheiden sondern an der einfachen
Frage welches System effizienter die
Krisen unserer Welt lösen kann zum Glück
sind die drängsten Probleme wie
Klimawandel etc nur gemeinsam zu lösen
also habe ich da Hoffnung und die eigene
Gesellschaft damit denn ich würde gerne
noch ein weiteres Kapitel in der Sendung
öffnen
Köster wohin entwickelt sich der
Weltfußball und vor allen Dingen in dem
Zusammenhang natürlich wohin entwickelt
sich die FIFA im nächsten Jahr steht
schon eine Infantino erneut zur Wahl
nach dem derzeit geltenden Statuten wäre
dass die letzte Wiederwahl was wird denn
was können wir erwarten jetzt vielleicht
bis zur Fußballweltmeisterschaft 2026 in
Kanada USA Mexiko
also der internationale Fußball ist ja
auch sehr komplex also wir haben einen
starken Schwerpunkt in Europa wo wir
gerade erleben dass sich eigentlich
immer mehr an Gier und macht zusammen
bald wir haben diese Bestrebungen zur
Super League also quasi die raustrennung
quasi der Superreichen aus einem bisher
noch leidlich funktionierenden
Solidarsystem selbst wenn man es auch so
eklige Weise macht wie die Champions
League wir haben auf der FIFA Ebene eine
Machtlosigkeit
Europas das muss man klar sagen
Infantino wird im März wiedergewählt
werden per Akklamation in Ruanda er hat
sich ja durch viele Leute Zuwendungen
und Aufmerksamkeit ja die Stimmen gerade
von den Zwergstaaten gesichert und die
Frage ist eigentlich will man das
wirklich ändern also gibt es
beispielsweise den europäischen
Verbänden ja kann man das ändern und
will man das ändern und ist man bereit
auch naja ich sag mal etwas schmutzige
macht Politik zu betreiben also klar ist
entweder sagt man man sucht die
Konfrontation man stellt beispielsweise
auch mal gegen Kandidat auf selbst wenn
der ein bisschen gedemütigt wird weil er
so wenige Stimmen bekommt gibt es
strukturelle Bemühungen beispielsweise
auch die Macht der FIFA zu begrenzen ich
finde es zum Beispiel ein Skandal dass
die europäische Politik beispielsweise
immer noch weg guckt komplett sowohl bei
den Super League Bestrebungen als auch
bei den Dingen die bei der FIFA
passieren in Amerika gab es
zwischendurch mal ein paar Bestrebungen
auch die FIFA als Mafia ähnliche
Vereinigung einzustufen das hätte
insbesondere was die sponsorenfrage
angeht viel bewegt jetzt sieht merkt man
hin zur WM 2026 will man doch nicht so
viel Ärger also am Ende stellt sich die
Machtfrage auch im Fußball wie
eigentlich auf jeder anderen
gesellschaftlichen Ebene auch und die
Frage ist will der DFB wollen die
europäischen Verbände was ändern oder
sind sie irgendwie abseits von ein paar
Protesten
Widerstand Leiste es gibt ganz neue
Umfrage von dieser Woche 57 der
deutschen 57% der Deutschen sind der
Meinung der DFB soll aus der FIFA
austreten das wäre jetzt sozusagen die
richtige Antwort auf die Zustände in der
FIFA Rebellen die einen Klick machen
müssen und dann sind 57
Wochen die Umfrage kommt sie ein
bisschen anders ausfallen aber es gibt
doch noch schlimmer wenn wir jetzt
rausfliegen naja gut dass man sich die
Beiträge spart okay
nur diese dass die FIFA offenbar ein
ganz ganz schlechtes Image hat wie kann
man als gerade die können die
europäischen Verbände der deutschen der
niederländische der französische Verband
wie können Sie sich dazu Wehr setzen
dass also das nicht in die Richtung sich
weiterentwickelt die Philipp Köster da
gerade der Chef der der UEFA sitzt in
diesem fifa-rat übrigens sitzt auch in
deutscher drin Peters der ich sag das
jetzt mal unvorsichtigerweise erheblich
dazu beigetragen hat das Schalke 04 an
die Wand gefahren worden ist der
verträgt Deutschland da ich glaube nicht
dass die Machtstrukturen aufweichbar
sind dann müssen sich ja mal schon viele
einig sein es sind sich ja jetzt in dem
Falle nicht mal die 13 europäischen
Mitglieder eigentlich die bei der
Weltmeister sind wie kriegen sie 55
unter einen Hut und dann wird er immer
noch locker gewählt weil er jetzt schon
die Zusagen aus Afrika Ozeanien Asien
hat aus Südamerika es fehlt nur noch
Mittel und und Nordamerika die werden es
auch machen weil sie die WM kommen dann
kann Europa jammern wie Sie möchten aber
der Reformdruck kann nicht aus den
Verbänden kommen das hat ganz ganz lange
Jahre von unten kommen es muss meiner
Meinung nach Druck aus der Politik geben
ich finde es ein Skandal dass ich die
Sponsoren überhaupt nicht äußern also
jeder druckt sich weg gerade die großen
Sponsoren aus adidas ist obs coca-Cola
ist obs viele andere sind es hätte
längst und unfassbar größeren stärkeren
Druck geben müssen
und eine erhebliche Anteil der VW Aktien
gehören dem Emir von 17% Anteil ich will
gar nicht alter VW allein fokussieren
für mich ist klar Sponsoren müssen
Einfluss eben sie haben enorm Einfluss
und sie müssen den Nutzen und ich finde
noch mal die Politik muss was tun es
kann nicht sein dass gerade auf europ
politischer Ebene dem alles zugeschaut
wird und man sie sagt ah da kann man
nichts machen es gibt eine klare
Verantwortung und jeder Politiker der im
Europäischen Parlament sitzt der auch in
den nationalenparlamenten sitzt und der
in irgendeiner Weise irgendeiner Weise
Interesse oder sich den Menschenrechten
und und und und und und universellen
rechten verpflichtet fühlt muss handeln
also es kann nicht sein dass wir sagen
das ist Fußball das geht uns nichts
anderes
Idee was man machen kann
um das zu verhindern Widerstand gegen
die FIFA bevor sie sich in Infantino
umbenennt
ich habe keine konkrete Idee ich bin
gerne bereit Lösungen mit zu gestalten
da habe ich kein Problem mit aber ich
komme eben nicht aus der Politik und ich
glaube auch dass das eben genau das
Ventile ist was es eben braucht und was
ich machen kann in meiner Position als
ehemalige Fußballerin ein und als
Menschenrechtsaktivistin ist tatsächlich
immer wieder den Finger drauf zu zeigen
und immer wieder die Leute darauf
aufmerksam zu machen und auch mit
politischen Entscheidungsträger vor
allem auch in Konfrontation zu gehen die
Frage ist ja geht das jetzt immer so
weiter oder wie lang geht es so weiter
man könnte ja auch eine andere Frage
stellen ist das möglicherweise die WM in
Katar ein ein Wendepunkt in der
fußball-wm-geschichte ich glaube ist
nicht das ist schnell vergessen aber der
Vorschlag ist ich habe auch 12 Jahre bei
der ARD Boxen moderiert da gab es einen
Weltverband der hieß WBA world Boxen
dann waren die sich nicht mehr einig
wird den Box oder den dann hat sich die
WBC gegründet boxing counsel und später
gab sie noch ein paar Jahren noch ein
weltver alle führen Weltmeister
vielleicht soll man eigentlich
gegenverband aufmachen und mal gucken
was draus wird ich weiß sonst auch
nichts
ja Katar das glauben Sie was welche wir
werden ja gerade schon gesagt mit dem
was das möglicherweise für Bedeutung hat
dass die Entwicklungen Katar
beschleunigt jetzt die WM auch
möglicherweise auch die negativen
Diskussion über das Land alle Fälle
sagen aber vor allem erstmal die
positiven Seiten das wird ja leider auch
weniger erwähnt ja es gibt ja auch gute
Sachen die sich verändert haben also da
noch mal ein persönliches Beispiel als
ich da vor zehn zwölf Jahren das erste
Mal hinkam das waren ganz anderes Land
im Herr hat man das auch gerade
beschrieben also nicht nur von der
Infrastruktur her und der Skyline
sondern auch wie die Menschen drauf
waren und eben wie sie mit dir
umgegangen sind als einer aus dem Westen
wie offen sie auch waren und da ist
schon sehr viel passiert also ich kann
mich erinnern dass ich da vor zehn
Jahren wenn ich mit auch
Geschäftskontakten Frauen
in Kontakt kam oder auch auf in der
privaten privaten Bereich man sich aus
Netzwerken kannte man sich irgendwo
treffen wollte selbst in London musste
man sich irgendwo in der Mall im letzten
district treffen weil das sollte nicht
gesehen werden mittlerweile kann man in
Katar ganz normal sich bewegen es gibt
viele Frauen in Führungspositionen das
ist natürlich zum Teil auch was was ein
Bild was gezeigt werden soll ist auch
ganz klar aber es zieht sich auch durch
sind wirklich viele junge
EntscheidungsträgerInnen sehr
verantwortungsvollen Positionen und auch
für die Menschen drumherum es geht ja
nicht nur um die Kataris ich habe ja
gerade gesagt das ist eine Minderheit im
eigenen Land sondern was machen Sie
eigentlich für die Herrscher an an
Menschen die ihn alle zu arbeiten und
ich glaube auch da und das haben auch
Menschenrechtsorganisation gesagt das
ist genau
nur für die WM Baustellen arbeiten kann
an dieser Stelle beenden
vier Jahren noch mal drüber das gleiche
Thema der nächsten WM ich bedanke mich
bei Philipp Köster bei tupperty kalt
weil immer hat man bei Jeremias Kettner
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer am
Sonntag um 13 Uhr bei
Programm Hinweis von mir Forum
Demokratie aus unserer Reihe
Minderheitenrechte mit dem Titel
Akzeptanz sexueller und geschlechtlicher
Vielfalt moderiert von Michaela Polster
aktuell ist und weiteres in Phoenix der
Tag mit Maja Weber darin unter anderem
natürlich zur Sondersitzung des un-
menschenrechtsrats in Genf Thema waren
die schlimmen Zustände im Iran die
bundesaußenministerin war heute vor Ort
in Genf und hat sich zu diesem Thema
geäußert bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
[Gelächter]